guillermo lasso cumplió un año en el
poder en un mensaje a la nación hizo un
balance de su labor frente a la pandemia
destacando la vacunación de 83 por
ciento de la población de 3 años en
adelante los excelentes indicadores de
salud nos han permitido estar entre los
primeros países de la región en retirar
el uso obligatorio de la mascarilla y
cuál es la obra de lazo en el primer año
de gobierno
y yo les digo la primera obra de laso ha
sido salvar la vida de 18 millones de
ecuatorianos
en materia económica hablo de un
crecimiento del 42 por ciento lo que
permite a ecuador posicionarse como el
segundo país con la inflación más baja
en américa latina' pusimos el nombre del
ecuador en lo más alto del prestigio
mundial
millones de ecuatorianos hoy laboran con
una tranquilidad que hace apenas un año
era inimaginable
pese a lo exhibido por el mandatario los
pueblos originarios realizaron su propio
informe del gobierno liderado por la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas del ecuador que el tema
combustible es el tema sistema
financiero el problema de los bajos
precios de los productores
la flexibilización laboral el ingreso de
las mineras a nuestros territorios el
respeto de los derechos colectivos y la
no privatización de estos puntos el
presidente de la república no ha
respondido en seguridad el mandatario
tampoco salió bien librado hoy por hoy
no podemos salir a las calles compañeros
la inseguridad
asesinatos en diferentes provincias
en las cárceles
ha habido muchas personas que han
fallecido dentro de las cárceles el país
se enfrenta a una de las peores crisis
carcelarias en años cerca de 380 presos
han muerto en motines desde que llegó al
poder y sus esfuerzos contra la
inseguridad en medio de una feroz
oposición legislativa se están quedando
cortos en la percepción ciudadana
la encuestadora perfiles de opinión
indicó que la credibilidad del
mandatario cayó al 21 por ciento en
abril en comparación al 68% que tenía
cuando asumió el cargo